uh it's too bad we couldn't do it in
studio though it would have been would
have been cool
i know you could have seen just how
small we are
studio is google says i'm five [ __ ]
seven so i'm on board with that [ __ ]
wait how tall are you six foot so it
says i'm five
seven it might have been changed now no
it's changed now six feet
so when i came out people were like
commenting [ __ ] like five
seven i was like like i don't even look
at the [ __ ] comments anymore
but for a while it was just like short
like short keying love i love you blah
blah and i was like
what the [ __ ] and then someone said
google has me at 5'7 and i was like
what the [ __ ] you're like i'm not
[ __ ] short
yeah it's like [ __ ] all my buddies are
over six foot anyway so i feel like the
short one but five seven just slander
but i'll like come on
hey what's wrong with five seven what's
wrong with that dude hey wait no
i'm just kidding because i'm not if i
was five seven i'd rock that [ __ ] too
hey listen if that's you that's cool
that's not me
yeah that's good yeah good dude i just i
just i'm not if it
if i was i'd be cool with it but i'm not
because i'll be pathetic
this is weird it feels like i'm watching
one of the one of the talking heads from
the show
yeah dude so like yeah and the be cut
dude those were
those were the worst so i watched the
show back finally it took a while
just because there's certain parts i was
kind of like damn like they got me at
the worst
like the worst moment but the beach hug
when you're sitting there talking to the
camera
like there was one episode i remember we
got
pretty much 5x the amount of liquor we
normally get
let's talk some more oh yeah yeah yeah i
can tell some episodes you guys look
bad like your eyes are like glass you're
like i feel like yeah
straight up like i was sitting in there
and i'm just looking at myself like dude
i am
current and you already know they're
getting like every answer out of me they
want and they use that same one for like
the next two episodes because it was so
long oh yeah i was like yeah
got you can you even say that do we have
to cut that out
uh no i think we're
i don't know yeah we probably can't talk
about production too much
but i mean i want to know
yeah that's fine that's fine to say just
not i'm sure i just can't be saying like
yo someone told me this or that
yeah yeah yeah yeah when you when you
like go to the
to the b cut room do they tell like i
always wondered like when you did the
challenges and you're talking about the
challenges as they were
happening or i guess like when you're
talking about [ __ ] that
happened what am i trying to say yeah no
like
when when okay let's say you do a
challenge and then you go
then you're talking about it they always
have you phrase it in real time oh like
you're in
yeah yeah like you're in present tense
but is it that you do the challenge and
they get you after and they go okay how
did this make you feel and then when
this person did this
is it just that yeah yeah i know that's
that's exactly how it is
we come back and uh just kind of how did
you feel in this moment
how was this and you talked about it
yeah did they ever make it
like do they do you ever give an answer
they say that's good say it like this
though
it's more of it's more of like we know
we know that's good but just be more
drunk when you say it
yeah no it's more more direct i'd say
kind of like if you're just talking
around the point they'll be like
you know we want you to hit that on my
head like hit that a little harder and
then you will
but you really learn how to answer the
questions without throwing people under
the bus
so you just talk around and you get to
it but then when you re-watch it back
it's kind of like
snaps just put that part in there and
you're like [ __ ] like
yeah so what's funny is i googled
carrington love island height and the
third
link is a reddit post carrington update
so
is he five seven or six feet dude i hate
i found out what reddit is
just just after the show [ __ ]
i know you guys don't know what it is
apparently but it's [ __ ] terrible
it's so it's so weird the conspiracy
theories
of like the show like there's there's
fans of people who like
make up theories like i saw one it was
like caleb caleb was bi and camden's gay
and
and they've been secretly talking what
like where did you get that from like
what the [ __ ]
how did they get your sex tape bro i
don't know right
i hacked the love island server and i
got your sex tape it's a wrap
hold on you you didn't know what reddit
was that's the part that
you just found out what reddit is and
how old are you 23.
dude i am doing it like i i've heard
about it
i just never when you're succeeding you
don't go on the internet like that like
the internet
is a utility it's just like it's the
most that's the most hot person [ __ ] of
all time just like
i just found out i just found out people
sit inside all day and post on a
what do you even call this don't these
talk to people in person that's
hilarious
they're not even like normal
conversations it's just like the
weirdest [ __ ] though
like the weirdest [ __ ] no offense to
anyone after using reddit but
damn dude
i am oh my god this is the funniest
thing this is probably the best segment
that we could
have ever asked for this is the funniest
thing i've heard my entire because we
constantly pretend like we don't use
reddit
even though we do and so to have someone
on here that literally has never used it
yeah it's [ __ ] amazing this is the
funniest thing i've heard literally my
entire life yeah i just found out what
reddit
is man god damn it so funny straight up
you might hear some power drills for a
second but uh mind it so yeah did you
have a good time out here how was it
no it was fun and i uh like utah is
awesome i'm not going to [ __ ] on utah
but the beach
that was just amazing like we had a spot
right at newport beach
um once we left la it was just you could
walk straight out to the boardwalk
it's just cool man it's a different it's
a different
lifestyle and i just like it do you go
to bear flag
that poke place in newport no
okay sounds good though yesterday
so what's the plan for you like um you
just going back to work or are you
doing a bunch of entertainment [ __ ] now
like
no hasn't been like transitioning back
into real life
after the show it's been
it's been weird for sure like i i wasn't
uh expecting as much attention i guess
i didn't think it'd be like that big and
i still don't even think like
like if there's some cloud meter like i
have like this much i'm not
you know i don't have a big head at all
right now but it was
it was cool coming out there's a lot of
love i thought there'd be way more hate
just because i was kind of like dating
on a dating show which you should you're
supposed to do but i mean i guess it's
frowned upon
i'm nice so i like the dig i like the
difference
people hate me because i was [ __ ]
dating on a dating show but you're not
supposed to do that
really you're not supposed to do that um
but no it's been cool yeah i'm not going
to influence i'm not going to do
any tick tock [ __ ] like that um my man
i i just can't like i am actually
getting into acting
i will do some modeling as well yeah i
have a pretty cool audition
around new year's for acting like a
really good series so i'm really excited
about that
i'm just going to try to you know shoot
my shot with you now that i have a
little bit of
a little bit of something to work with
you know yeah oh yeah so did you
did you get like when you left the show
was it right away they like
you got an agent and a manager and [ __ ]
like that or
no so i'm with cbs for
i'm on a contract for like almost a year
still
so they rep you um yeah they rep all of
us we have to reach out to them for like
brand deals or anything like that
um but yeah i will be looking once
that's over to get into
you know work with working with someone
else uh right now it's modeling
i have a couple people i'm talking to
and i'm allowed to fully just
send it with them but i think everything
just has to go through cbs for like a
little bit of time so
yeah right yeah all my modeling stuff
has to go through yeah same
our wraps yeah all my model and [ __ ]
it's just
yeah the brand gear totally know how to
totally know how that goes
getting hit by a model man you're
[ __ ] checking we want you to
come take a picture i'm like yeah no
sweat man yeah
talk to my bicep agent
you